it's always really exciting to be at
Stanford yeah I think you guys have it
special
here and I've visited a few campuses
around the world and every time I come
back it's really awesome to be here so I
just want to give you a little bit intro
but before I do that I actually want to
take a little bit of a poll so I can
kind of have an idea on who you guys are
and what you guys want to be so I'm an
engineer and most review maybe aren't
engineering and maybe you can you can
take a look at this question and say
what what do you want to do when you
grow up
so just as a show of hand so the options
are be a founder of a company stay in
academia have a people management role
in industry have some technical role in
industry and no idea
so just number one who wants to be a
founder all right actually Wow
he's half the class who wants to stay in
academia okay well one or two who wants
to have a people management role all
right two three or four who wants to be
have a technical role in industry two or
three and no idea oh wow almost half the
class all right great
so that's actually a pretty pretty great
mix so I actually was probably throw my
career probably it ranged all five like
when I started I was probably five when
I was like undergrad and then it went to
four and then it went to two and then it
went to three and then one and then
probably I met one now and probably
wanna go back two maybe three eventually
or maybe two so it'll change but I can I
can go into it so just a few of the
highlights I just want to talk about
just my background where I came from
talk about artists our company and then
lessons learned along the way so about
me
originally from Vancouver Canada and I
got my undergrad degree in mechanical
engineering at the University British
Columbia I I was always interested in
cars I was part of the the SAE kind of
that we did the Formula one cars at the
time or and and was always interesting
the airline
actually from there I actually worked in
industry and being from Canada I always
thought that was the that was the best
thing in the world you know working for
these large companies I worked in
Germany I worked in Canada and and being
there as being part of engineering teams
I realized that's not what I wanted to
do it was it was political is
bureaucratic who was slow there were
processes and I realized if I were gonna
move up anywhere in my career I had to
do something different and at the time I
decided hey I'm gonna apply it a few
schools in the States and try to get a
try to get a good spot and going to grad
school and so I did and I got into the
Aero Astro program I didn't have funding
I when I arrived I had a and I also
didn't have a plan of how I was gonna
pay for school so when I arrived I I
knocked on doors I literally knocked on
doors to try to get ta za raised trying
to find funding and I did I found a
great professor and we came up with a
business plan of how we're gonna like
fund my research and fund what I was
gonna do which was in Formula one cars
so he was an Emmy because I tried
knocked in all the Aero Astro doors and
they were all closed so Emmy was a great
opportunity and that's how I got started
really
so I actually worked in got a funding
through that Toyota Formula One team and
we did a lot of research on aerodynamics
of the front wheel assembly of the car
and that took about few a few years I
hadn't intended to do my PhD but it just
kind of happened that way you know there
were a lot of master students that that
were there at the time that said well I
probably won't do a PhD but that
eventually changed and I kind of kinda
got sucked into it and said okay well
I'll stay a few more years ended up
being four or five years but throughout
that process I kind of got sucked into
this whole entrepreneurship thing I mean
there was there were programs or
opportunities and and that's kind of how
I mean I kind of how it all got started
I actually took a took a was called pre
at the time which was a program in
innovation
ship which has changed it but and now
there's all kinds of programs and then
in 2011 I started arturis and that's
that's the history so but before I get
into what arturis is just a little
background on how we got started I I was
working in my little lab at the corner
of campus really close to the circle of
death and and somebody literally knocked
on my door and through a mutual friend
she was trying to look for somebody in
physics who could simulate airflow
through his upper airway because he had
seen a doctor that was gonna do surgery
on him and he thought that if he was
going to go through surgery he didn't
want to do that and maybe he thought
there's a figure a better way to predict
how that surgery would end up if if only
that you could do some sort of
simulation or fluid simulation so and I
was the CFD expert at the time and
that's how this idea to use simulations
or just or to use kind of cloud
computation kind of got started so so we
worked on this idea and submitted it to
this pre program and and that's kind of
where it all got started and originally
arturis was not about the this problem
of trying to solve upper airway disease
using CFD we actually tried that for
several year or for a few months and and
that was challenging because going
through the whole fundraising process to
trying to raise capital trying to find
out how we're gonna sell it in
healthcare it's challenging so we
actually hit a lot of roadblocks and so
in that year basically in 2012 we we
learned a lot about the the industry in
the business and the way we learned a
lot is by going out and talking to
doctors talking to a lot of people who
knew the field I knew how this
technology could be used and throughout
that process we met two other physicians
at the time we're at Stanford
Albert Hsiao and tres vasana Walla who
are other co-founders and that's really
where it all got started and they were
working on a technology at the time
which was called 4d flow which is a way
to naana basically measure blood flow
using MRI and throughout that
partnership the four of us decided to
form a comp
and that's how we started really from
sleep apnea and really moving towards
cardiovascular mr and now we do
something even differently so with that
what is arturis so the artists are our
mission is to really could create an
automated intelligent imaging platform
to unleash the real world data to make
healthcare accurate and data-driven so
that's what we're all working towards
and it's pretty broad and what really
our focus has been in the last few years
is really we've developed a zero
footprint medical imaging analytics
platform with deep learning that has FDA
clearance that's what were that were the
first company to do this in the world
and and what is medical imaging
analytics so what is a medical imaging
platform mean well what we're doing is
we're collecting data from from MRI
scanners from from any scanner really in
the world
and we're pushing all that data to the
cloud and we're allowing physicians
senator users to log in and process this
data in in real time and process this
data further a clinical workflow so
we're solving real clinical problems for
them and and that's where the idea of
machine learning or deep learning comes
in you can you can get very intelligent
and smart as to how you can automate a
lot of their workflow by using by using
these types of technologies just in
terms of the the size of the opportunity
or market it's the just the medical
imaging market alone is a nice for
post-processing is about 3.2 billion
dollars so right now it's very local
you have very legacy software in in
these types of hospitals and it's it's
pretty archaic I mean even the
algorithms or everything that's that's
that's out there so it's very far behind
the Facebook's or the Amazons or the
apples of the world and there's a reason
for that it's primarily in regulation
primarily in in you know the impact that
that a potential software vulnerability
can can have on a patient so there's a
lot of roadblocks in healthcare or
getting getting software out also
there's other issues with regards to you
know working with hospitals selling
infrastructure to hospitals selling
software to hospitals the the time it
takes to get money or the sales cycles
are very different from conventional
applications
so in terms of kind of in imaging today
and and and what's the current status of
the market it's it's actually moving
from right now a paper use so physicians
in the past have gotten paid for every
procedure and it's moving to a
value-based care model so what does that
mean really physicians who are getting
compensated for outcomes compensated for
how well a patient you know gets gets
better but and not really about I'm
gonna make more money by doing this
procedure so and that's that's that
incentivizes everyone to in the right
direction the field does suffer in
general from lack of consistency it's
difficult to track patients across time
across different institutions it's
difficult to aggregate data and the
intelligence of a single of the work
that's going to be done on a particular
patient is really limited to the to the
user or to the physician that and
whether they've seen that a certain
issue or not and that data is very
rarely shared across institutions across
the world so there's a lot of collective
intelligence that you could bring by
having a centralized system and that's
really what what we're doing there's
also a need to make imaging more
quantitative so think of the idea of
trying to quantity quantify certain
structures and images or and extract
additional parameters from from these
MRI machines you can extract so much
more than just black and white Anatomy
images there's a lot there for example
blood flow and lastly you can combine
different types of data for for
biomarkers the ultimate goal really is
to do predictive not predictive analysis
to identify what are the what are the
features that cause a certain disease so
there's a big opportunity here for for
change in the conventional kind of
imaging market it's again local the
interfaces are very old-school it like
measurements and reports lack
consistency or structure everything is
is either oral it like dictated or you
have these handwritten reports or it's
all very scattered it's difficult to
make any sense of this data and and
again automation has been difficult and
primarily because that they haven't had
access to
data to try to automate these these
things how we're changing that game is
really using the cloud and aggregating
that data on that in that single place
to be able to provide insights so we're
providing very structured reports and
quantified reports to make it consistent
I think consistency in healthcare is
very important so that you can have you
know you can you can track my new
changes over time and make sure that
they're not biased by the reader that's
that's very important and and what do we
do or what are our main tasks so they're
primarily around detection detection of
what's in the images of tumors or other
other types of things
classification tracking segmentation
these are fairly you know these are the
building blocks of what of what our
back-end does in terms of as I mentioned
this local approach today is really CPU
based not a lot of you know advanced
rendering or quantification segmentation
where we're moving to is this idea of
pushing the data out to the cloud very
similar to the way Tesla's doing with
with their cars if you push the data out
you can get so much smarter and and our
back-end is it's fundamentally GPU based
we usually pews everywhere in our stack
from rendering quantification and
segmentation the machine learning it's
it's all has to be real-time and fast so
just a few of the core technologies but
behind our our system obviously the
cloud computation the deep learning it's
a zero footprint browser-based interface
we have a unique piece of core
technology that actually keeps all
patient information in the hospital
something that that that nobody has done
successfully using the cloud before and
of course we have the FDA and CE mark
and several regulatory clearances to
sell our product into those markets and
as I mentioned what we're kind of
changing the game in terms of how we're
using this data to our advantage
hospitals are just now really realizing
the value of that data that's sitting
there and and we want to leverage that
data and we want to make it accessible
not only for us but also for everyone
else out there and and the way we do
this is is again it's a collective
intelligence
we can we can take that data and get
smarter over time so you could think of
it as as people use use our platform we
learn we learned what they're doing well
we learned the mistakes we're making and
then we're just constantly getting
better releasing updates and and finally
yeah every physician benefits from all
the thousands of other experts in the
field so it's really a great great use
of making qual quality analysis or
quality care and it's in this race
especially it's important to have access
to data and really the company that has
access to data
the fastest can really accelerate and
become the most intelligent and the way
I think of this is let's say test on
Google Tesla has as 200 million miles
driven versus Google has an order of
magnitude less and and they're they're
ahead and they can stay ahead because
they have that at the collective
intelligence and and really it's the
same thing in our industry as well with
that I want to give you in a sense or a
demo of our system and and how it works
I think it just helps to put to put a
picture to it to words so so this is
this is our system we we again have a
way to access images anywhere in the
world where we have clearances and in
Europe and United States but really
we're deploying our solution across many
different other countries so a physician
logs in clicks on a particular study
that they're interested in and then then
they can look at this study anywhere
anywhere in the world so I'm just going
to reset my view here so what you're
looking at is a 3d image of of the body
so what I can do is just just natively
in the browser I can look at about five
gigabytes of data and the way we do this
is we distribute this load across across
it basically a GPU cluster of resources
and we spin up and down dependent
depending on the the load of the of the
of the system so it's it's just 3d and I
can just hit spacebar here and it's
actually 40 in time as well so you see
the
heart beating and there's extra
dimensions as well so what i can do is i
can turn on blood flow so well i can
really in one simple 10 minutes can
really see everything that's happening
in your body and this is a this is a
brand new piece of technology that's
we've partnered with General Electric GE
to to commercialize and to deploy
eventually across all them and our
machines in the world that's that's our
really first application and it's not
only visual it's also looking at you
know you can quantify several things so
here this comes back to my CFD or
compeition fluid dynamic today's is
looking at streamlines so looking at
where the where the flow is going red
here is showing areas of high high flow
or high speed and and blue is is low
speed I can also turn on vectors so
vectors are it can tell me the direction
of flow as well forwards or backwards
its quantitative I can measure blood
flow through any turning artery or vein
so in this case I've made a region of
interest and I can measure measure flow
in this case it's 1 or 1.7 liters
forward or net flow I could I can make
new measurements as well so let's say I
want to measure the flow and the the
pulmonary artery the single click it
attracts that pulmonary artery it finds
it and it makes it makes new
measurements so in this case one point
six eight liters per minute and so these
are the types of tools that radiologists
want to use they want to make imaging
quantitative and consistent and this is
just one way to do that and it's all
about being able to identify to track
and classify what type of pathology is
this in in oncology to trying to assess
what type of tumor it is the looking at
the texture there's a lot of parametric
data out there that you can jack you can
aggregate in terms so this is this is
the 40 flow product we we also have the
product of looking at other types of
data so I can look at brain brain
so this is a an example of lesion
detection so this is a this is all for
research do so only at the moment it's
not on the market and what I can do is I
can go to what you're looking at is
several different types of sequences
they're called so different types of
scans and you can combine the different
scans together - - - - - to get
different types of information so if I
go to lesions here I click on find
lesions what about the system does is it
it identifies where these solutions are
and it identifies the enhancing region
of the the lesion the core of the lesion
as well as the the whole the whole tumor
or and and it quantifies it so it does
really football you metrics segmentation
and you'll notice that I didn't have to
do anything really the back end of all
this is machine learning and deep
learning and we have a production
inference service where the data gets
sent up it's in real time it's it's it's
it's it's it's tracked segmented in it
and pushed back to the browser and in
seconds and from there obviously they
have simple tools to be able to to
annotate or to track or to change the
rendering there's there's all kinds of
specific rated weight radiology tools
that you can use to to report on the
patient ultimately a few other examples
looking at chest CT or natl detection so
what I can do here is I can just
maximize this particular patient here so
you're probably familiar with just
looking at kind of chest x-rays so CT is
just a kind of a 3d chest x-ray so what
I can do is you know I'm here I'm just
rendering the full chest cavity and
depending on that on the way of how you
how you render this data you can you can
actually try to identify tumors or
nodules so here I click on find nodules
and it'll automatically track and
identify where these nodules are
something that's very time consuming
today using conventional radiology so
radiologists
looking at thousands of images and it's
time-consuming and they can miss them so
this is a perfect tool for for machine
learning so with that I have all kinds
of demos but I'll stop there and if
there's time at the end we can go
through some some other cool stuff but I
just wanted to give you an idea of of
practically what what we do and how it
impacts the the clinical care so so so
with that our first our first kliklak a
clinical application is cardiac mr.and
and why is that important
it's it's it has enormous value for kind
of the pain points specifically in
trying to diagnose structural heart
disease so what's happening inside
someone's heart whether their valves are
leaking whether they have a hole in
their hearts whether they have a single
ventricle there's there's really
structural issues that a lot of people
have and it's difficult to diagnose
these using conventional approaches like
echo or echo echocardiography you have
to be really an expert to try to
identify what's what's in these images
cardigan MRIs and specifically this
technique is different in that you just
need to acquire a box and a technician
can just acquire that box very simply so
there's advantages there it also
provides an additional metric of the
flow data something that in imaging
today just is not there it's a in terms
of kind of what are what are kind of the
whatever value add here is that we're
providing something that's a 10x
difference and it's important to have
really a very important 10x product I
call it because it's difficult to just
sell something that is incremental in
hospitals there's a big burden to
actually get something sold into a
hospital and it's that's why you need to
have kind of your Trojan horse to get
into the door provides something really
of a clinical unmet need and then expand
from there and as I mentioned so this
this is our this is our system here so
that the conventional way of doing this
is very manual it takes it takes on the
order of half an hour to an hour to try
to extract for example volumes of your
ventricles and we can do that in seconds
now so it's really that's why it's a
paradigm shift compared to their manual
techniques and then
using very very simple tools to just
click a click a few buttons and get get
all your answer very quick very quickly
these are a couple examples of of how we
use the deep learning and how he's
probability so on the right you see the
probability maps there for the long
again on the bottom you see the
probability of where we think the
nodules are and we take that information
then extract contours out of that so
that these contours are editable and
physicians can edit those contours and
those edits get fed back into the
training data and that's how we get
smarter and learned over time as I
mentioned we are partnering with with GE
healthcare and it's that that's a great
partnership because we can develop the
product and they have the sales force
and and distribution to be able to get
it out onto the market something that's
very expensive for us to to just to
build out ourselves so if that's why
it's important to have both direct sales
channels but also indirect sales
channels and and leverage the you know
the the larger companies out there so
it's it's a very very important
relationship that we have and also that
they they're great at marketing and
great at by pushing the product out and
it's it's a great partnership that way
so we we showed it that this big
radiology conference at the end of last
year and it was really was that one of
the highlights of the whole conference
of those 60,000 people there and artists
one the best
radiology software and best new
radiology company so we were very proud
about that we really have a great team
it's just a little kind of history about
the company what's very important for us
in terms of milestones is getting FDA
clearance and getting regulatory
clearance to sell our product that's
really out the way our barometer power
how we're measured we we incorporated
our waste we really raised our first
round in 2013 we just had a few people
initially and then for a few years we
developed the product and then we raised
our second or second round or a round in
2016 we're grew to about 15 people and
now we are
around 40 people and didn't raise our
next round we we have a very rich
pipeline of new products in apps coming
out and we were developing both the
platform and a new applications so
that's in a nutshell just in terms of
team as I mentioned others we have four
co four co-founders and we have the
different groups for regulatory quality
strategy
machine learning software products so we
have a you have did a lot of different
teams and sales and and we work very
very effectively with with one another
in terms of status we've we're we are
active in about 40 40 research sites and
have helped over 7,000 patients so it's
and what's great is because we can count
we know exactly what how many patients
are coming in and and how people are
using our software something that's very
unique in this industry yeah
so with that I'll I'll go into some of
the lessons I learned along the way I
think when I started I had no idea what
I was gonna but about to start and I can
I can kind of I can imagine myself in
your shoes today and thinking what what
do I want to do and hopefully some of
these lessons will will he'll help and
it's just a random mix of lessons but it
just it just helps helps us try to think
about that so so the first thing I'll
say is find the right partners you trust
I think doing things by yourself yes you
can do it the companies have done it
before but it just helps having a
partner having it having a co-founder it
just you can bounce ideas off somebody
and and it's just it just relieves some
of the stress and some of the
responsibilities and and it's just
extremely helpful even my my co-founder
says the same thing he started it by
himself he start his first company by
himself and he said it's just so much
easier just having having a partner the
issue with that though is you have to
think about whether you trust this
person and
and whether they're committed to this
also in terms of like how are we gonna
hang our we gonna spend on this idea
because a lot of you if you have an idea
you may not be working on it full time
you're maybe you're still in school and
you may feel resentful if somebody's
working harder than others and what's
interesting is that what you'll do is
you may try to get fancy with how you
split split the equity in terms of how
how involved someone is to start off and
I will say keep it to keep it simple I
think just because somebody is working
full-time for a week on a particular
project doesn't mean that they should
get more revenue or want more equity
split because it hopefully you're
building a great business and a week
isn't gonna make a difference and just I
would say structure in a way that makes
it successful long term and and everyone
is incentivized it's not easy no it's
not easy to do but it's it's it's really
important with that leverage the
incubators that are around here if you
have an idea there's now so many
incubators so just to give you an idea
the artist has been through now for and
growing so we started at startx
in 2011 which is a fantastic program it
gives you access and accelerates your
business so fast especially initially
you just don't have the funding to to
just incorporate or to you know think
about payroll think about lawyers legal
contracts infrastructure servers
hardware there's so much just initial
investments that maybe you need just to
provide a proof of concept before you
get friends and family around so
startups can definitely help you there
and if you don't get into startx there's
other incubators all the way around here
we after startx went to the hattery
which is a mini beta up in the city and
we then move to UCSF we were part of the
qb3 incubator and we now just started at
TM CX which is an incubator at the
Houston lead at the medical school there
so it's again leverage leverage all the
infrastructure or
kind of the resources that you have
around you super valuable
the next is bored so you probably won't
think about this early on but as you
raise your you're you're kind of first
round if you can do it with friends and
family your own personal money and
that's not an issue great but if you do
get investment from from a VC or some
other investment vehicle think about
your investors I think it's really
important to to to to trust them and
make sure that you have control and and
you're all aligned there's been stories
endless stories about you know boards
not agreeing with the founders and and
it's really important when you talk to
investors make sure that there's a
mutual fit because that is I can't I
can't say that how important that is and
for us we've been extremely lucky we
have a we have a great board and we're
definitely all all aligned lastly is is
the network I call it the Hoover tower
syndrome the idea is everyone has sticks
around here and everyone helps them
helps in a different way and it's and
it's extremely it's a useful tool that
you should leverage the everyone here is
involved in some forms with Stanford
through a through a contact or your
university or just through VCS or
there's there's so many people that know
something here so they grow your network
and and and leverage the resources that
you have is specifically around Stanford
and Stanford is is very unique I can
tell you we probably could not have done
what we've done so far if we were up in
Canada or if we were up in Europe it's
such an advantage to be here in Silicon
Valley yeah you have no idea we have
very similar companies that are trying
to do the same thing in Quebec and it's
just they're just not getting traction
and when they when they try to pitch to
VCS here it's just not the same so again
having headquarters having founders
local is really really helpful and not
it's not to say that then you can expand
and grow your business in those other
countries so we are headquartered here
in San Francisco but we have offices in
Canada and in France as well and you can
expand the next lesson I've learned is
the product market fit
and you've probably heard of this and if
you haven't the kind of the first
Business School class will talk about
this and specifically for us in
healthcare it's really about fitting
into a clinical unmet need so you really
have to identify a really a pain point
or an issue that's people are willing to
solve and people really need that's
really important I can't emphasize that
enough what I'll say before you have a
great technology a great idea just spend
a little bit of time doing the market
analysis to see if it's if it's a
worthwhile market because I can tell you
there's so much technology out there but
if it's really not about if it's not a
big enough market or it's not clear how
you're gonna sell it or make money
that's it's just not gonna work out so
that is very important I would say
before you start read a lot of
post-mortems and if you go to hacker
news or just Google postmortem
I start up there are so many stories of
other companies that maybe are in your
space that have failed and you can just
learn so much about what they want what
they've done wrong and just learn from
that and then and then move forward I'd
also say with that is don't be a what's
called a Walking Dead there's actually a
lot of companies that are just
scratching or just hanging on by one
last thread and maybe just have an have
been doing that for the last 5-10 years
and and that's not something that you
want to do and so it's really important
to know when to pivot especially early
in the in the process don't be afraid to
pivot if it's not working out and and
and that's what we have to do we really
started in sleep apnea which it was a
tough market for that particular market
you just didn't do CT scan on a regular
basis so that helps tremendously it's
just you know having the courage to say
hey it's not working let's just find it
find a new route and lastly it's big
market if you're pitching to investors
and the market size doesn't have a
billion in it it's challenging to say
the least
now that's not to say that you it'll
never happen
but investors nowadays are looking to
invest in overs the googles of the world
and they have limited time and bandwidth
to invest in smaller markets so you
really have to have an engaging business
opportunity for them and an upside for
them so market size is obviously very
very important the the other lesson I
learned is around revenue and what I'll
say it's it's fairly simple to try to
get to a million bucks in revenue but
passing the 10 million 10 million dollar
mark is is challenging and the reason
why I say it's challenging it's because
of this idea of crossing the chasm this
is another picture that I'd that's
that's that's very common is just that
you have this idea of of the innovators
the innovators who are there people that
will buy your product just because it's
cool and amazing then you have in the
next category the early adopters and
whether you have this big Delta between
the early adopters and the early
majority of people that will buy your
product and so crossing that chasm is
very critical in terms of getting to
stay in growth and it's especially in
health care the health care is driven by
regulations and guidelines and and laws
and it's it's it's challenging to get to
the to the tale of this graph and the
late the late majority of the laggards
is really half of their population it
takes time to in order to get to to get
there and that's why you know getting
past this revenue mark is is challenging
I also mentioned follow the money that's
why it's really important to understand
you may have a great product market fit
but the idea is if you don't know where
that money is coming from or how to tap
into that it will not work and
especially in healthcare it's very
convoluted and complex you have an
insurance you have brokers you have the
hospital's payers and it's just you need
to tap into that system and again it's
it's it's challenging to understand how
you how you can see how you can take a
little skim off the top and everybody's
trying to do that especially with the
changing and regulations and now and
administration things things are things
that are in flux for sure
the next is successes in the people not
the technology so again you you kind of
have to have a great technology to start
and if you don't then you're probably
not to get funding but it just helps
having you being surrounded by great
people and and I can't emphasize that
that enough is just this is a picture
that we took during our during our
retreat and this is about maybe half of
our team here but it's really important
this too that you trust your team around
you Matt and then you bring in a a
quality people I can't can't have as
emphasize that or company culture is
extremely important and I call it a no
ass rule basically one but one bad
person can ruin your company culture and
I want to emphasize that ego is it's
really the the root of all evil if you
have one person has a big ego and you
have the rest of the company that are
really incentivized or and trying to hit
the company goals and versus this person
has an alter ulterior set of goals
it just clashes and so far we've we've
been very lucky
knock on wood we have we'd have great
people but I've just known stories you
read post-mortem said if you get people
in there that that have a different set
of objectives it's it just ruins like
company culture Apple is a very great
example I mean Steve Jobs initially had
a had a great vision about what he
wanted to build and he had a great early
team and they were all aligned but what
is eventual when you get big enough you
just have different business units that
are all pushing for their team in a
different way and it's very challenging
just to just to be able to grow that
culture even when the companies the
thousands of employees and I'd say
actions speak louder than words I I
really like the people on my team that
that I that I that I trust the most I
guess are the people that just just do
the job that just hit their targets
without saying anything people that come
to me and saying hey I need a raise hey
I'm looking for a promotion that that
really is
it it just it's kind of forced versus
the people that are in the corner that's
that do their job and that do the job
extremely well by instinct III look at
them too and I compensate them typically
higher just because I they're doing the
job and they're thinking about the
company first in terms of kind of
learning the lessons fire fast so if
even if you look everyone make makes
mistakes but it's really important to to
make sure that you don't cause a cancer
in your company we've been we've been
very lucky again
but it's hard it's it's hard to do to
get to get rid of people but really you
have to think about it as part of the
business and think about how I can grow
the business and and I'm not trying to
create a personal relationship with
everyone but it's really about how do I
get the most value out of everyone here
and push the company first and that's
one of the most difficult things I've I
have to do is just you know making these
very difficult decisions motivation is
is extremely important so how do you
keep your team motivated we have a we
have kind of a culture ambassador on our
team and that's also one of my roles as
chief operating officers it's just
making people feel engaged and motivated
and wanting to work there every day
that's what I want to spend my mo the
most most amount of time on right now
and it's not on algorithms
I mean it's when you when you just start
off you're gonna be working on the
technology but if you want to be a
founder you're gonna realize you're
gonna move very quickly away from that
just because you're wearing so many
different types of hats and you're gonna
be like again further and further away
and yes you can attend those meetings
but it's gonna be a meeting it's not
going to be an in-depth analysis so if
you want to be a coder and also be a
founder of a large company it's just not
gonna work and so like I said I spend
most of my days thinking about how I'm
gonna motivate my everyone just to
continue to work there and that's
through the values and through the
through the culture that that that that
were that we're building I also
used tools to our advantage so we use a
lot of different metrics independent
analytics internally so like a tool
called moon map which is a great kind of
survey that goes out to all the
employees of the company and that tells
you whether people are happy whether
people are frustrated and the product
and their progress for the week and you
can track that and you can track it by
team and it's again tools that just to
help you do your job and we use tools
for for everything
and lastly feedback
I think feedback is really really
critical it's trying to understand and
communicate with with everyone in the
team and get feedback 360 feedback so
your direct reports should give you
feedback and and and and you should get
feedback too you know and and vice-versa
I think what's what really retains good
employees is the positive relationship
with their manager and and then being
challenged I think that that's there's
been studies on this and it's really
really important how many minutes did do
I do I have like okay great I just have
a few more slides the the next thing is
lessons learned so if any of you are
interested in health care what I'll say
is healthcare IT software is very
different from medical device software
so so you'll hear about a lot of apps
that are in the health care space that
collect data and that push data around
it's very different compared to medical
device and well what I'll emphasize
about that is if you're creating a
medical device you're a regulated you're
in a regulated environment and what his
regulations mean it means the whole slew
of infrastructure and documentation
before you can sell your product and one
example is what's called a quality
management management system this is or
QMS this is a whole set of processes and
procedures on how you run your business
so it's think of them as SOPs or
standard operating procedures each
country requires a certain unique set of
of SOPs and you always going to need a
full-time team just to make sure that
that's your procedures are in line with
the regulations that change on a yearly
basis that's a very core component of
having of selling medical devices and
think of it every device that you own
today
we'll probably have a C II label on it
now if you look at your iPhone it says
see that having a C mark means that you
need to have a quality management system
in place and that requires a lot of
infrastructure and support and
documentation the next thing is design
controls so one thing that's yeah that
you can do as if you're not selling a
medical device is you can hack something
up very quickly you can productize it so
you can push it to the Apple store and
and I start making money very quickly
that's not the case in medical and for
medical software you need to have very
specific design controls which means you
know having a design inputs to providing
certain set of requirements upfront you
need to be able to develop based on
those requirements you need to be able
to test do the verification validation
and there's a whole set of very very
specific set of milestones before you
get your product out and it's it's it's
time-consuming and how does that fit or
that waterfall type of software
development fit into agile software
developments of being able to just hack
something together iterate very quickly
that's uh that's that's an issue and
that's something that we're still trying
to solve today is how do we quickly
iterate on the product get feedback but
also push it out as quickly as possible
that's like I said very tough problem
also I mean test-driven development we
what we try to do is really write the
tests upfront and make sure that that's
that that we that we use those tests and
and the integration testing frameworks
and all of that to make sure that our
medical device is safe and effective so
like I said all those things you
healthcare IT companies may do but it's
just an order of magnitude more work to
try to get something regulated because
you need to prove that works you need to
have the data to support that it works
and either clinical trials or or having
data with it or have users use the data
so it's it's very very important the
picture to the left is actually
our latest submission it was I was 13
inches tall several thousand pages and
it's a lot of work so that's again you
would never have to do that if you're if
you're publishing an app I'll also
mention this particular slide of how
important it is to communicate these are
also kind of lessons that again you
don't learn in school of how to work
with the team I mean yeah they'll maybe
put you in a team but how do you really
communicate effectively and and pass on
information from one team did to the
next so this is an example of a customer
asking for a rope swing and here you'll
see that how the customer explained it
you know maybe I'm a rope swing with
with three steps how the project leader
understood it so this is really really
relevant to us like we we have customers
talking to us every day we have product
managers in that second category and
then those are requirements get sent to
the engineer which then writes these
requirements outs in this case came up
with that design then you pass them to
the dev team the dev team takes that and
they have no idea what the customer
wants and they build something like that
the sales team will undoubtedly try to
sell something magical even though it's
half-baked and doesn't work and there's
no documentation typically you have you
have the what we have the operations or
service team that goes installs it again
there's no communication how the
customer was billed how the how the
helpdesk supported it and what the
customer really wanted so that is a
funny cartoon but it's truly what what
what's very typical and in what we see
and every team is really important for
the clinical further for the end product
so what I have there on the right is how
important is each team to to making the
products be successful and again these
are some of the things you just don't
don't learn in school what I'll mention
here is kind of transitioning from
academic to entrepreneur really focuses
really requires focusing on commercial
efforts so the
don't be a technology looking for a
problem I think that's very important
and it's hard to it's hard to detach
from the technology focus on the people
management on the hiring on the
operations or the processes and really
the the go-to-market so how are you
gonna sell this product how are you to
market that those are really types of
things that are difficult to just
extract from with that I I will I think
what we are is it's a time almost I'll
just mention a start-up is a roller
coaster promotions you're gonna be happy
one day and and angry another day I
would say be even keeled and because
it's extremely stressful I'll say the
second thing is delegate it's really
important to know when just to step out
of a problem trust the people around you
empower them to make very important
decisions next thing for us is hire
great software developers and software
development teams specifically for us
and we talked about this 10x product
well there's the 10x uniform unicorn
about but also just the 10x team I'll
say entrepreneurship isn't for everyone
it's stressful it's it's you know
there's it's also you have a lot
responsibilities you're anxious you're
anxiety and maybe it's not for you and
if you if you want to try things out
maybe go work for start-up and maybe
being an early employee at a startup
just to see if that's right for you
and lastly applying for the job so let's
say you don't want to be a founder of a
company and you want to apply for a
certain job I have just a quick set of
of little rule rules that I'll say is be
very specific as to which companies you
want to work for target them on
CrunchBase go to CrunchBase comm and see
the starts that have recently gotten
funding and then focus on those
companies and focus on who's hiring
who's the hiring managers and don't just
send a resume and cover letter send them
a message and and be very specific as to
how your skillset can help them you have
no idea how many resumes I receive and I
just never look at but the ones that
just semi direct business plan to say
hey I know I can solve this particular
for you I actually look at so that's
just one one lesson also lastly this is
my five month old newborn and I'll say
it's it's challenging to be a family
person but also be an entrepreneur so
take risks when you're young it's it's
much harder when you have a bigger
family and with that thank you yeah
that's a great question I went when
you're small I think you have to focus
less on it and it's really organic
really that the people that you hire the
two or three people that are there to
start off you really don't think about
it but yet you it's it's a one-degree
connection between what you want and
still and the values that you have with
with with the people that are just core
around you so it's so it's just organic
that way as we grow it's much more
challenging to have this this kind of
self-replicating effect and that's why
we put in so much more effort to try to
keep that same company culture so if I
were to say in an ideal world it'll
always be the same and it has been
that's the best answer but it's probably
not the same it was what it was when
there's five people but we're working
it's constant evolution where we're
constantly working towards and and it's
not just I want to build a culture
that's not just a nine-to-five job it's
it's all about making people motivated
and wanting to work there yeah
I like to ask how did you get the same
pomegranates
sure you come work with a just idea and
these expand and go to the NGOs and get
I mean before you make up for that or
you make so great question so question
was around how we got our seed funding
and a couple options was you know you
you make the product and you try to
raise capital or you just have an idea
or back in the envelope idea and then
trying to raise capital off that for us
it was really about before our seed
rounds is just getting enough friends
and family cash to try to develop some
proof of concept that we have something
there and maybe that some something
could be something that you license from
the from other companies or that you
license from Stanford which was in our
case what we did so so we just graze a
little bit of money just to have some
core piece of technology and then from
there the way we raised our series seed
round so it's it's it's unique it
depends on the it depends on the on the
on the technology but I think you'll see
less and less of paper napkin kind of
checks I think it's so competitive right
now that investors are looking for
something real something that shows
traction and that's why you almost need
either users you need revenue or you
need something attractive in order for
them to invest yeah
that's the new mission and market
message for them I am wondering how did
you how do you make sure that the market
you thought is really important
yeah so the question was around the
market analysis and and how did we do it
and what and how did we assess that it
really wasn't a market need there and I
would say we didn't really do a good job
and actually with this
we said oh there's a great technology
let's let's try to sell this and I think
that the real weight is to start doing
is talking to customers talking to users
there's a lot if you go to the B school
or the business school there's a lot of
resources there in terms of looking at
the market and there's there's market
reports so it going going there and and
reading those reports aggregating data
paying for data paying for surveys those
are all things that that we do now and
we spend tens of thousands of dollars on
surveys market analysis
customer interviews just and and you
know the blinded studies so we do a lot
of different things to see if there's
really a market there and like I said in
the beginning if you don't have money
you just talk to a few people but I'd
say talk to people outside of Silicon
Valley especially if you're selling a
product that's global because you can
get so skewed here in the valley
especially if you're trying to sell song
in Stanford everyone at Stanford is an
expert go talk to some hospital in rural
Ohio and just see if they're willing to
pay for something that's where you
really learn
you